.
AM FORMEAST WEEK. MAKESON T WEE.
BACK WITH C
CORRPO ROMANS
AND CNN ANCHOR
JULIA C AND CNNRRPOD. M WEE
A HUGE  6.6 MILLION IN
ONE WEEK, A HUGE NUMBER. H ITAS
YW ECONY.
>> IT IS RE, YOU ANYTHING INONLL
IS O CLOSED,
OTHER OFF H CLORYTHING IPAUSE.
THIS IS A COSE
THE ACA MARKET.
YOU'VE NEVER JOBS
GONE
SOME OFFURLOUGHS,
E
EEPLE SORT
ACTIVE A BY SO  WHENND ECONOMY.
BUT THIS IS A TRAGIC KINDF
NU, E WONDERI WHENY' GOING THEI
HOIR RE.
ABOUTECKS,ERBIG, SG, PROBABL
UNDERCOUNT THE NUMBER PEOPLE
WHO LOST THEIR JOBS BECAUSE
PEOPLE C'T THROUGH TO THEMENT OS
IF YOU GO TO THEIT
SAY, PATIENT, WLLILL BE IVE.
>> TALK MORE ABOUTLI G.
.5 MILLION, THA UNDERESTIMATINGG
ARE,HAT'S HARD TO  IN W IS BEII
APEOPLE NG ANECDOTAL
T LET GIVE YOU NTEXT OREEEING
WITH THE NUMBERS WHEN WE'RE  16
SIST
THRES.E TALKING ABOUT
UNEMPLNT RET15 THIS MOMENT.TOW,
S NUMBERS,HESE ARE
LI CHILD T STAGE. SEEINS IN
GETTING MONEY INTO THEM.
THE OTHER POI IAN BRING REKNOW,I
MEDIUZE
ENTERPRIS,D HALFGIRANCE. WHAT YI
% OF THE LAST THR EKSU
OF H MIDDLEEM
HERE IN THE UTEESNDAROUND THE W.
SOISHA
CAN'T GET MONEY,T THIS
LA
COUNTRY THAT W N  NUMBER OREOSBU
SING ILL  T ANDS
>>NHA
INO HAV
NEW CN POLLUT
PEO AHE CURRE
N JUST %
SA THAT'NTRONTATP IN ONE MONTH.
IT IS INST PPL THEY WILL NEXT
UNEMPLOYMENTUMUEY ARE.
>> WELL,HA
UNUSUAL, JOHN,UT T
SIIND OLVIN.USUALLY WHEN YOU HAE
WONDG, WELL,CY RESPONSE,
WRON DOENDONOMY?
WE KNOW T IS
ME THAT PUBLIC HPAEMD USLIP IT
THE AMERICAN HAVE TEKS MORE THAT
UNIT SRT OF  B OFRK.
THE  ECONO WEVER, PEOPLE UNDERA
GE TOPHE PANDEMIC TOALLOW EMY TO
PRRE ON
WE SORTF THEGE OF THE FIRSTIG B
TC PUTTING  BILDI SMALL
BUSINESSES, WHIT,
SAWAEND
HOSPSMPS AND
OTHER TOPLE.
I THINK THERE IS GOING T
DOCUMENT
THMA T
TOGETH ANDOVERCOME
DIVISIONS.
>> THERERE THOSE TOMPETING
ONOU CHRISTINE
ROMANS.O ME A WERCE
BIOL S
SI ADDING MONEY FOR
STATES AND LOC AND
AL>> WELL, IT IS SOING,OMISTS,
KNOW, PNI
ECONTSUST PH
THE MON ASK TLATER, KNOW.
AF PARTY WAS
BORN OUT OF SPENDBORROWED MONST
OF PROBLEM YOU SS
BACK TTREETIRD FOREMOST, RIGHT?
THETATESLL THA  THEY -- T
ONES WHO PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
CITIZENS, RI
THLP.
THE F THERE IS A THIS FAEY'REEE
TESTING PRTHAT'S GOING TO TEY.W
ON OTHER. EYES, OF THEABOVE.OPTE
ERS LIKETHIS, WHENWE  POINT THIT
THOSE THING SUCH PIVOTAL ONHINK
AND THEMUIASECOND.
WE A TALKING ABOUT MLI MILLIONST
TIME THE
PANDEMIC.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE CAAH THE
E IO
NEED TO KEEP M
THEIREMBE AND
MEDIUM BUSINESSE OUND 80 STHE N
ND TO THE STATES.
CAN'THO CUSONHE NEXT FOUR
TO SIX WEEKSSOMPTA
ENABLE US MORENGLY OFF THE BACK
>> JULIACHATTERLEY J
HARWOOD, CHRISTINE PRECIATEHE C
DREA